Narrator:
MAKING RETRO-STYLE TOASTERS
IS THIS BRITISH COMPANY'S
BREAD AND BUTTER.
WHILE SOME OF ITS MODELS
ARE NEW DESIGNS
IN A VINTAGE STYLE,
THIS ONE IS AUTHENTICALLY RETRO,
IN CONTINUOUS PRODUCTION
SINCE THE 1960s.
THEY INSTALL
THE BREAD EJECTOR.
NEXT, THE HEATING ELEMENTS.
BEING A HIGH-END TOASTER,
THE ELEMENTS ARE SHEETS
OF PURE MICA,
A MINERAL THAT'S HEAT-RESISTANT
UP TO 1,800 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT.
THEY CONNECT THEM WITH
ELECTRICALLY
CONDUCTIVE COPPER LINKS.
THEY MOUNT THE SWITCH
THAT SELECTS THE NUMBER
OF BREAD SLICES TO TOAST.
THEN THEY INSTALL A RED NEON
LIGHT THAT ILLUMINATES
WHEN YOU START THE TOASTER
AND TURNS OFF
WHEN THE TOAST TIME HAS ELAPSED.
THE TIMER SWITCH HAS A BELL
THAT SOUNDS WHEN
THE TOAST TIME IS UP,
AT WHICH POINT THE SWITCH CUTS
THE CURRENT TO THE ELEMENTS.
THEY ATTACH THE DIALS
FOR THE SLICE SELECTOR
AND TIMER SWITCHES
AND CONNECT THEIR WIRES
TO THE MAIN POWER CORD.
THEN, THEY PLACE
THE TOASTER COMPARTMENT
INTO THE BODY AND SCREW ON
THE TOASTER'S
STAINLESS-STEEL TOP,
THE PROTECTIVE FILM NOW REMOVED.
THEY FLIP THE TOASTER
UPSIDE DOWN
AND WIRE UP THE ELEMENTS.
THEY INSTALL THE EJECTOR KNOB,
POSITIONING ITS SPRING
AGAINST THE BREAD EJECTOR.
WHEN THE BELL RINGS,
INDICATING YOUR TOAST IS READY,
YOU MOVE THE KNOB TO RAISE
AND RETRIEVE YOUR SLICES.
A TECHNICIAN TESTS THE TOASTER
THOROUGHLY, ENSURING
THAT ALL OF THE ELEMENTS HEAT
TO THE CORRECT TEMPERATURE,
THAT ONLY THE SELECTED
SLOTS HEAT UP,
THAT THE TIMER IS ACCURATE,
AND THAT THE BELL RINGS
WHEN THE SELECTED TIME ELAPSES.
[ BELL DINGS ]
THEY INSTALL THE REMOVABLE
CRUMB TRAY,
THEN CLOSE UP THE BOTTOM
OF THE TOASTER
WITH A VENTILATED BASE PLATE.
NYLON FEET ELEVATE
THE TOASTER FOR VENTILATION
AND TO PREVENT THE SCREWS
ATTACHING THE BASE
FROM SCRATCHING
YOUR KITCHEN COUNTER.
THE STYLE MAY BE RETRO,
BUT THIS 1960s-DESIGN TOASTER
WAS AHEAD OF ITS TIME
WITH ITS ENERGY-SAVING
SLICE-SELECTOR FEATURE
THAT STOPS THE TOASTER'S
EMPTY SLOTS
FROM HEATING UP UNNECESSARILY.